Salut à tous, c'est Pêcheur de Trésors
Aujourd'hui on a fait une petite pause au bord de la route
Au bord du canal, bien entendu, ce n'était pas prévu
On a déjà quelque chose de bien lourd
Ou de bien envasé
C'est quoi ?
Ca c'est un morceau de panneau
Il y a un truc qui est resté en bas
Si vous voulez un aimant, on vous conseil de passer par Maison de la Détection
Nous on utilise l'aimant Barbarian
Celui là a un peu de vécu mais il résiste encore
Il a une force de 1600 kg
Vous avez le code promo PECHEURDETRESORS qui vous offre 5% sur toute la boutique
Même sur les détecteurs de métaux
Le lien est en description
Ca paraissait tellement lourd ...
Il y a une vase fou dans le coin
Impossible de trouver de vieux objets
Bien joué
C'est l'autre partie
On va le réparer
Oui, faisable
Pour le réparer, il faut faire ça
Voilà !
Comme neuf
Maintenant, ce qu'on va faire pour être tranquille pour pêcher
On va le mettre là
Qu'est ce qu'il fait Rasta ?
Allé, on continue
La boule de pétanque qui fait plaisir
Aussi une pile
Jolie dépollution
T'es jaloux de ma boule de pétanque ?
Ouais, elle est restaurable
Le petit Rasta qui se promène
C'est bien
Il paraissait très lourd mais beaucoup moins maintenant
Il vient
Il peut dater de la guerre
Un cadre de moto ...
Il ne date pas du tout de la guerre ...
Ca reste un bel objet
Il est quand même vieux
Au moins 20 ans qu'il est là
Ouais mais l'étiquette est encore belle
T'as vu Rasta ? C'est des canards
Il veut peut être faire partie de la famille
Oui, peut être qu'il se prend pour un caneton
Là j'ai eu quelque chose
Un morceau de voiture
Donc ici il y a du scooter et morceaux de voitures
Ca promet
Là les gars, une trouvaille de professionnel
Pour aller jeter là bas au fond et le sortie de la vase
Pour moi, c'est encore un cadre
Je pense plus gros
Ca vient
C'est lourd quand même
Il y a au moins 20kg
Il y a plein de vase avec ...
Ce n'est pas si vieux pourtant
Voilà !
Le deuxième
Surement encore des Booster
Ouais, ils en jettent vraiment de partout
Ca va le faire
Il est brusque, c'est une femelle ?
Non, c'est aussi un male
Rasta, reste là
Au revoir
Désolé pour le vent, ici une espère très rare
Je viens de tomber sur un nid de Despérados
C'est vraiment peu commun
Ici j'ai des couverts on dirait
On a une belle cuillère
Tiens
Regardes, tiens
Il faut savoir que une canette d'aluminium coute environ 2 centimes d'euros
2,4
6,8
Les paquets de tabac, ca ne vaut rien
Celui là non plus
Malheureusement, il y a qui ont dû tomber dans le canal
Mais on arrive à 18
Pendant que Quentin est en train de galérer dans le joncs
J'ai fait mon premier lancer
J'ai quelque chose
Rasta, fait attention à la route
Restes là
J'ai quelque chose
Je sent que c'est super intéressant
Il y a du poids pour un premier lancé
Tu le vois ?
Il y a l'air d'y avoir du tissu
C'est un sac ?
C'est bon ça !
Ouais, c'est bon signe
On va le monter pas trop près de la route
Ca c'est du premier lancer !
On dirait un sac lesté
Ouais, on dirait un sac lesté
Ca pu ça les gars
Ca sent bon tu veux dires !
On ne sait pas ...
C'est aimanté !
Tu crois que ça peut être quoi ?
Une arme
Pas un truc dangereux j'espère
C'est l'endroit parfait pour jeter, au bord de la route
Il avait préparé son balluchon, regardes comme il l'a attaché
Ca sent la très bonne trouvaille
J'espère que ce n'est pas un cadavres lesté avec du fer
On va le vider
Vas y doucement, c'est peut être dangereux
C'est très aimanté en tout cas
Des outils ?
J'ai déjà vu ces choses
Qu'est ce que c'est ?
Il y a une clef plate cassée
Pourquoi ils se sont embêtés à jeter ça ?
On dirait des ailettes
Pour des outils agricoles
Comme quoi, parfois on pense avoir trouvé quelque chose de dingue mais non
Ok , bon, ça reste marrant
Ouais pour moi c'est des morceaux d'outils agricoles
Tu crois qu'elles sont cassées ?
Elles n'ont pas l'air cassées
Par contre la clef, oui
Une trouvaille bizarre
Je m'attendais à mieux avec le sac
C'est vachement lourd, regardez les bulles
Ca vient
Quentin, t'es prêt ?
Une jante
C'est surement la même personne qui a jeté ça
Peut être
Dites moi si vous reconnaissez ce type de jantes
Je ne m'y connais pas du tout
Là on est sous un nouveau pont
C'est une Nationale donc ça roule assez vite
Regardez, Rasta fait comme le renard du tag
Attention !
Il y a des clefs aussi
Regardes le portable !
Il est incroyable celui là
Il est vraiment beau
Tu crois qu'il est sorti avant le Nokia 3310 ?
Il est sorti en 1999, comme la naissance de Baptiste
Il fait parti des premiers avec l'antenne comme ça
Il est peut être collector
On va vérifier ce que l'on a attrapé
Oh ! On a bien fait de vérifier
Regardes ça mon petit
Une munition
Quel calibre ?
Je ne sais pas
18 34 P25 S*
Elle date surement de la Seconde Guerre Mondiale
J'ai des choses
Des clefs aussi
Cool, celle là est en laiton
Ici c'est la fonte
Regardez déjà tous ce qu'on a sorti
C'est pas mal, on va voir combien on en tire
103 euros récupérés
Ca met fin à cette session de pêche comme il faut
Nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo de pêche à l'aimant